we start with breaking news tonight new
information about the shooting that
happened outside of Von tobel middle
school earlier today in the Northeast
Valley sources telling our 80s now
investigators that a campus monitor may
have been struck by a stray bullet fired
during an unrelated incident the
shooting happened about 12 30 p.m right
near Pecos and Kerry now we have to
stress this is what sources close to
close to the investigation think
happened at this time and right now
those sources believe neither the school
nor the victim were even targeted the
school monitor is expected to recover
now that incident prompting lockdowns
though at both Von tobel middle school
and another nearby school and we have
Team coverage tonight on the shooting
Madison Kimbrough taking a closer look
at how bad violence is in that
neighborhood and has reaction directly
from parents but first eight news now
investigator Kyle Payne was on scene all
day and has more on what happened
including reactions from students
trapped inside
students with their hands up locked in
their classrooms while police scoured
and secured the Middle School an
exclusive cell phone video obtained by 8
news now this was not an active shooter
but an isolated incident police say
there was no active shooter but to
illustrate the confusion as events
unfolded we know it was an active
shooter active shooter or not Von tobo
Middle School near Pecos and Kerry went
into hard lockdown and Jeffers
Elementary which a butts Von tobel went
into soft lockdown leaving parents on
both campuses anxiously awaiting while
police reassured them that no students
were injured it was around fifth period
where they announced that there was a
hard lockdown because somebody got shot
outside the school we were in there for
like about like two hours I would say
there are 1200 students enrolled here at
Von tobo Middle School at least two of
them are sisters and they were not in
the same classroom during these
harrowing moments it was a very scary
experience 14 year old Jasmine Reyes and
her younger sister spent those long
hours in lockdowns separated from each
other adding Untold heartache to an
already terrifying situation I was
scared and we heard like knocking from
like the police
and handle like moving and once they got
in I was wondering if my sister was also
safe safe and holding on tight to her
little sister after a hellish day at
school Kyle Payne 8 News Now